you got to ask some real questions about
if washcloths are for the poor which has
been a classic ymh debate that's been
going on for a long time now and has
plenty of people actually angry which
you've doubled down on it's not even
close to the craziest thing you've ever
said on a podcast so as a comedian does
it ever surprise you what people choose
to get upset at versus what they can
accept as a joke it it surprises you
like the moment you go oh wow but then
you go like yeah this is what people do
you know because they also you also
realize that in like if you want to use
wash glosses an example the way that
that kind of went viral is that somebody
Clips like 30 seconds of a conversation
and then somebody who has no idea who
you are or what this is just sees that
and they go oh sh this is like very
inflammatory the way that this is said
and they don't get that it's kind of
part of a longer larger conversation and
that it's that you're basically like
doing a bit right but you don't get any
of that when they clip it out but I'm
also used to that